TO QUIT.
A QUICK PROGRAMMING NOTE, AS THE
DEBATE OVER IMMIGRATION HAS
RISEN TO THE TOP OF THE NEWS, A
NUMBER OF FIGURES ON THE LEFT
IT'S NOTABLE NOT A SINGLE ONE OF
THEM HAS OFFERED ANY EVIDENCE TO
SUPPORT THE SLUR OR REBUT THE
ARGUMENTS WE MAKE EVERY NIGHT.
THEY JUST MAKE LOUD NOISE WHITE
SUPREMACY.
THE REST OF THE MEDIA DUTIFULLY
ATTACK THAT.
THE LATEST TO ATTACK THE SHOW IS
WAYS TO RESPOND TO CRYSTAL, A
FORMER INTELLECTUAL WHO IS ON
TWITTER AND WE CONSIDERED THEM
THAT'S WHY HE NO LONGER HAS A
FULL-TIME JOB AND THOUGHT IT'D
BE MORE EDIFYING TO WE BELIEVE
IN IMMIGRATION.
THE POINT OF OUR POLICIES IS TO
HELP AMERICANS.
GOVERNMENT IN THE FIRST PLACE.
IF PEOPLE IN OTHER COUNTRIES
ENJOY AND BENEFIT FROM WHAT WE
DO, THAT'S GREAT.
THAT'S AN ADDED BONUS AND WE
WELCOME THAT ALWAYS, BUT IT CAN
NEVER BE THE MAIN POINT OF WHAT
WE DO.
AMERICANS ARE THE MAIN POINT.
THAT'S ALWAYS TRUE NO MATTER
WHAT THE ISSUE IS.
WHEN THE CONCERNS OF FOREIGNERS
TAKE PRECEDENCE OVER THE NEEDS
ILLEGITIMATE.
THAT'S WHAT'S BEEN HAPPENING.
VOTERS UNDERSTAND THIS AND THEY
HATE IT.
THAT'S WHY THEY ELECTED TRUMP.
ELECTION RESULTS WERE A HARD
SLAP IN THE FACE.
A REBUKE THEY COULD NOT ACCEPT
AND REFUSE TO LEARN FROM.
INSTEAD THEY DECIDED THEIR OWN
COUNTRY WAS IRREDEEMABLE AND ITS
POPULATION SHOULD BE IGNORED.
THAT'S HOW WE WOUND UP WITH
IMMIGRATION POLICY MOST
AMERICANS DON'T SUPPORT BECAUSE
THE PEOPLE MAKING THE POLICY
DON'T CARE IF YOU SUPPORT IT OR
NOT.
IMMIGRATION HAS UPSIDES.
MANY IMMIGRANTS ARE IMPRESSIVE
PEOPLE AND ADD GREATLY TO THIS
COUNTRY.
WE KNOW A LOT OF IMMIGRANTS LIKE
THAT.
WE ALSO KNOW SOME WHO SHOULDN'T
BE HERE.
NOT ALL IMMIGRANTS ARE THE SAME.
SOME ARE WORTH ADMITTING, SOME
ARE NOT.
AMERICANS GET TO DECIDE WHO
MAKES THE CUT.
IT'S OUR COUNTRY AND OUR CALL.
MAYBE YOU BELIEVE IMPORTING POOR
PEOPLE RICHER AND MORE STABLE
BUT BEFORE YOU DO THAT AND
IMPORT THEM, YOU SHOULD EXPLAIN
EXACTLY HOW THAT'S GOING TO
WORK.
WITHOUT SHOWING THE REST OF US
THAT'S AN HONEST QUESTION AND